Jessica threes out this week letting you
hijack cows fly around in your wingsuit
blow up bridges and growl yourself to
just about everything speaking of which
a lot of games were keen on the
grappling hook this year and here are
five of our favorites
in the zombie apocalypse you really do
want to maximize your speed and
traversal options to keep from becoming
food for the undead ward that makes the
grappling hook and dying light pretty
damn important unfortunately you won't
pick up your grappling hook from the
get-go you'll need to unlock it and
achieve survival level 12 before you can
enjoy zipping your way around ledges and
rooftops it has a bit of a cool-down to
contend with but the grappling hook is
essential in getting out of sticky
situations quickly particularly if
there's a speedy viral zombie bearing
down on you since they're able to climb
buildings to chase after you you can
also use it to explode bombers and
generally get from place to place way
faster than your crappy speech could
carry you it makes sense in a single
player game to want to speed up your
traversal but in multiplayer speed and
positioning are absolutely essential so
you'll probably want to keep your
grappling hook handy in battlefield
hardline sadly you can't latch on to any
old ledge on any old building but the
ones you can connect to will be all
helpfully highlighted for you while
you're heading up to the roof to get the
jump on some cretinous who are on the
ground for some reason you'll probably
want to cross your fingers that you
don't get sniped while you're shimmying
up oh that somebody doesn't cut the rope
you're actively climbing once you make
it though you're golden when he's not
busy finding epic loopholes to maintain
his hole no killing ethos Batman is a
big big fan of the grappling hook of
course that man is too cool and rich to
just have your regular old
run-of-the-mill grappling hook his
gadget is called the grapnel gun and is
similar to the bat claw which can
prevent covering a wall but is instead
used as a means of transportation
basically Batman needs the grapnel gun
to look badass and get where he's needed
in Gotham in Arkham nights you can
upgrade it to launch Batman several
metres over a roof granting him a
massive speed and I see why they
bothered to include the Batmobile when
they gave us the grapnel gun is beyond
me parkour is one of the first things
you expect from an assassin's Creed game
but
traversal is made by easier and more
effective with the inclusion of a
grappling hook in assassin's creed
syndicate jacob and evie use their
grappling hooks to quickly scale
buildings in Victorian London so while
climbing buildings has never been a big
problem for out who did AC heroes the
grappling hook serves as an additional
particularly crucial tool to let you get
across to other buildings once you're
already up high you can easily Traverse
huge gaps by making your own zip lines
and of course take down your foes from
above finally I think we better loop
back to what appears to be the most
insane use of a grappling hook this yeah
because Just Cause 3 really does seem to
be taking it to another level perhaps
the most prominent image of the
grappling hook being used in Just Cause
3 at the moment depict Rico grappling
himself to a propane tank and riding
that thing into the sky that on its own
leaves our other contenders in the dust
but the nature of Just Cause means that
the madness does not stop there
Amon Studios really aren't interested in
putting restrictions on you you're free
to grapple to anything you want
including firing off another grapple mid
real I know that doesn't make sense and
so do the devs but it's probably cool
enough that you won't care since you're
basically spider-man you can also use
your grappling hook to attach things to
other things and reel them together
letting you catapult explosives cows or
whatever you want into the distance you
can eventually upgrade your gadget to
allow a maximum of 6 cables at once
letting you set up heinous webs of
destruction to mated with a single
grapple button then you're down in that
comment section if you're a fan of
grappling your way around town and I
will catch you again next week